autre grande surface du crime
les deux aussi extraordinaire de pierre
bellemare publié avec la signature aussi
de jacques antoine au peut-être on
pourrait dire un mot c'est de votre co
auteur jacques antoine bell jacques
antoine louis et à très grande hauteur
de radio c'est une spécialité d'écrire
pour la radio puisqu'il il faut décrire
pour être dits non pas pour être lu et
c'est tout un style et jacques-antoine
imposé à la radio son style il ya de
cela une vingtaine d'années et c'est
donc un homme de radio très important et
nous avons travaillé toujours ensemble
depuis depuis près de trente ans
maintenant et nous connaissons tellement
évidemment que lorsque jacques écrit
quelque chose et que je le lis j'ai
l'impression que de m'entendre ce volet
il ya une sorte d'osmose complète
veuillez multiples sont des textes à
lire entendre plus tôt mais alors il
faut les refaire pour les pour les lie à
brive est absolument seul connaît pas le
texte maintient europe un homme non
c'est très près si vous voulez c'est le
même esprit exactement mais il est
impossible totalement impossible de lire
avec intérêt un texte qui est fait pour
être dit ce je crois au mans 70
histoires extraordinaires vous attaché à
ce vous donner un sens vous voulez
rétablir le sens du mot extraordinaire
oui oui oui hors de l'ordinaire n'est
pas forcément dans le bon sens il est
peut être dans le mauvais sens on s'est
attachés si vous voulez à sortir des
dossiers de police qui en effet avait
toujours un aspect extraordinaire hors
de l'ordinaire
pas forcément par la personnalité du
criminel par la personnalité parfois de
de sa femme de son entourage de
l'inspecteur qui le poursuit lucie fort
douteux leur me parler du des histoires
qu'elle a le plus frappé dans ce livre
je me disais c'est l'histoire du veston
vous donner c'est à dire l'histoire d'un
psychanalyste américain que le docteur
bruxelles qui a donné à la police avant
que celle ci ait commencé son enquête
simplement en envoyant des lettres
anonymes du criminel
elle a donné le portrait absolue mange
aussi bien aux physiques au caractère
dudit criminel même la région des états
unis où il était probable qu'il vivait
sa nationalité car il s'agissait d'un
émigrant et finalement lorsqu'on a
arrêté ce personnage il correspondait en
tout cas ce qu'avait dit vous allez vous
seul avez donné un dernier détail il
avait dit et si vous le rencontrez je
suis à peu près certain que sa veste
sera boutonnet à deux boutons et
lorsqu'il s'est présenté à la police la
demande est allé s'habiller pour les
suivre il voulait être bien habillé
poursuivre car il n'a pas nié son clone
du tout et lorsqu'il est redescendu de
sa chambre il avait une veste l'été vous
tenez à deux boutons alors là le côté
extraordinaire c'est évidemment
l'enquète psychanalytique je dirais
d'octobre c'est bien souvent le crime
quand même qui donne
non bien sûr bien sûr l'histoire c'est
le psychanalyste qui est extra mais dans
cette histoire c'est le sionisme qui est
étonnant le faire venir à lyon il a
donné 15 départ je crois si cela fait
quinze ans qu'il est en règle
c'est rocco qu'une seule fois ces
charlots comme celle-là c'est voit elle
pas quand on en trouve un vrai on est
alors en jubile oui la pierre bellemare
tout de même une demi heure chaque jour
à europe 1 avec votre voix chaude et
vibrante plus un livre de 500 pages sur
le crime il est qu'il est un criminel ça
fait quand même beaucoup de publicité
pour le crime ne serait pas aussi bien
sûr oui oui oui mais alors là je crois
qu'il nous a vraiment n'avait pas besoin
de nous toute façon parce que là vous
l'avez d'ailleurs dit dans dans l'avant
propos de votre édition d'une part la
plupart des enfants beaucoup de grandes
oeuvres s'inspirent directement
d'affaires criminelles monde des
affaires criminelles et s'en inspire
car finalement je reviens tout petit peu
en arrière mais lorsque nous faisons des
recherches pour trouver donc ces
histoires c'est à dire qu'il ya une très
grosse documentation qui est
indispensable et notamment dans les
dossiers américains
on s'aperçoit parce qu'on ne connaît pas
tellement les faits divers américains
ont déçu par deux journaux que bon
nombre d'oeuvres cinématographiques
majeures américaines sont en fait des
adaptations de faits divers américain
que l'on retrouve et que je raconte
d'une autre manière mais c'est
exactement le
le film parfois celle du cinéma
américain qui a été adapté le stade ans
donc je crois que tu viens nous ont pas
attendu les pas besoin de publicité
particulière en cours certains son coup
parfaitement inconnu oui c'est exact
c'est exact c'est vrai je reconnais bien
sûr mais je crois que alors là il ya
deux positions en face à cette émission
on peut évidemment dire que c'est
uniquement pour cultiver de sensationnel
bon d'accord d'accord alors on peut dire
oui c'est entendu
et puis alors on peut passer au deuxième
stade et dire que il est intéressant
quand même de connaître tous les
ressorts tous les mécanismes qui ont
fait agir ces gens et notamment ce qui
me paraît encore plus intéressant les
ressorts les mécanismes qui ont fait
agir la société face à ces gens bon par
exemple je donne une histoire qui a
traité le sujet me croquer dans son
livre et que je traite dans le mien
qu'il a pour le procès jacques ou bon eh
bien il est certain que la latte la
personnalité même de cet accusé et
l'attitude du public et sa position
sociale ont passé par dessus le crime
lui même je dirais et sont plus
intéressants à étudier que le christ
lui-même les dons il ya je crois un
arrière-plan quand même très intéressant
pour vous la faire jacques où j'ai
remarqué que vous vous donnez le nom 2
un baquet
et puis vous vous l'appelez z vous
donnait pas son nom le nom de la
personne tuée
oui david et pourquoi 0 pris l'habitude
bardy s'est insurgé lundi carrément cela
qu une audi z
oui non pas spécialement non nous aurons
pris un peu sous 30 ans bruit non non on
a pris un peu ce parti pris oh non il ya
souvent les noms à vous juger non il ya
souvent des noms ont changé toutes les
histoires sont vraies très souvent les
noms sont fous est-ce que vous pensez
que beaucoup de criminels méritent leur
gloire
non non quoi c'est à dire que healy a
démis des criminels qui ne méritent pas
leur gloire et des criminels qui n'ont
pas une loi réclamée rite du raku pas où
je prends deux exemples
j'ai raconter deux histoires de crime
passionnel qui ont été jugés a très peu
de temps d'intervalle d'ailleurs dans le
premier crime c'est une femme qui tue
son mari elle aura anna toute la
construit très banal j'étais un monsieur
très important elle aura toute la
considération du jury il sera quasiment
équité et puis et ça c'est la 6e minute
vedette l'a bien et puis l'heure après
il ya une criminelle très désagréable
parce que les passionnés mais c'est
surtout elle est orgueilleuse et ça
c'est très sain on admet le crime par
passion n'a même pas tellement le crime
par orgueil or ces il s'agit de pauline
dubuisson et alors là effectivement et
basta personnage qui a été très mal
juger je crois en son temps par le jury
j'entends par là que l'indisposé
continuellement et les d'étonnant de
voir que ces deux crimes passionnels
dans des conditions d'accord différentes
quelques mois d'intervalle l'a amène un
quasi acquis tenant alors que l'autre
amène une condamnation grave est bien
évident que là il ya eu un criminel met
en vedette qui a bénéficié de
l'indulgence et il est un autre qui n'a
pas bénéficié le plus intéressant c'est
celui qui n'a pas bénéficié à mon avis
de l'allusion du jury à mon avis et vous
avez vous à les rattraper une injustice
grâce à votre livre on a essayé de faire
un vrai portrait de pauline de puissance
et qu'elle est de toutes vos histoires
extraordinaires celle qui vous
paraissent elles mêmes c'est celle ci
qui vous parlez plus exposés d'une femme
qui m'a vraiment fasciné je dis vous y
avons consacré d'ailleurs ce qui est
exceptionnel dans notre série
d'émissions quatre émissions et cela
mérite et jacques antoine c'est terrible
beaucoup passionné vos sauces pour ce
sujet je dois dire que c'était un sujet
très passionnant c'est une femme tout à
fait étonnant qu'on pourrait revenir
plus tard
[Musique]